ho sempre pensato che l'inizio di questa
serie sul mio canale sarebbe stata molto
emozionante sentita ma non c'è manco la
musica nemmeno bene grazie
benvenuti a questo nuovissimo video sono
parigi star di youtube a lei era una
vita ragazzi con iniziare stadio valli
non l'ho mai cominciato perché non sono
mai stato sicuro ora chance io non sono
mai stato sicuro ragazzi della della
particolarità di questo gioco perché lo
bello visto che a quanto ne space flight
incredibile se sarebbe stato curioso
sinceramente oggi è arrivato il giorno
di prova restarvi vallet altro sono
esattamente i miei capelli nei periodi
del periodo d'oro questi vili tengo
piano non è familiare fin qua non ne
fattoria direi a questo punto la fa
vittoria però non è molto era abbastanza
scontato ma chi se ne frega vuol dire
cosa preferita
non lo so la bla bla bla bla pizza con
le con le patatine non solo ma il cazzo
mi significa passati alla mia nvidia
3090 ma che cacchio vuol dire preferenza
animale direi questo gattino ma non so
dirti il motivo ok siamo persi questa è
una partenza ai massimi livelli cioè su
youtube c'è anche una cinematica c'è
babbo natale che dorme e per il mio
nipote adorato voglio che tu abbia
questa busta sigillata a lui schioppa e
l'afa vittoria diventa mia
vediamo vediamo trattato qua c'è una
scimitarra caso verrà il giorno in cui
il peso della vita moderna
ti schiaccerà eto'o spirito luminoso si
spegnerà di fronte alla vuotezza cresce
madonna ma qualche profondo
pazzesco non so cosa sia sta roba sul
comodino la voglio quando ciò accadrà
ragazzo mio sarai pronto per questo dono
ora lascia riposare il nonno
vent'anni dopo scritto in numeri roma ma
perché sarò in ufficio
no vabbè ma bellissimo c'è proprio tutta
la storia sto male no ragazzi allora io
non ho mai visto niente di stabio ballo
e magari poi avete visto un miliardo di
gameplay di the life is better with jojo
giolo a questo sono io una scrivania
sporca lurida pro britta la lettera del
nonno quando quando la vita ti ti ti
diventa vuota eccetera il nonno detto
apri questa lettera caro favi cei
se stai leggendo di avere un gran
bisogno di cambiamento lo stesso accade
a me tanto tempo fa avevo perso di vista
la cosa più importante della mia vita
i rapporti rari con gli altri alla
natura così abbandonai tutte mi trasferì
nel luogo a cui appartenevo davvero ti
allego qui l'atto di quel luogo il mio
orgoglio la mia gioia la fattoria fa
vitto ria si trova a star di huawei
sulla costa meridionale è il posto
perfetto per inizia nella tua nuova vita
questo è stato il mio dono più prezioso
è tuo
so che farai un'ora nome di famiglia
ragazzo mia buona fortuna ti voglio bene
non se lewis è ancora vivo assoluto la
parte mia va bene che se gli luiss che
bellissima partenza
mamma mia mamma mia
salve devi essere faringei robin sono
roba da falegname locale è una gnocca
clamorosa il sindaco lewis è ancora vivo
mi ha mandata via prenderti per
accompagnati a casa tua lui è già lì sta
mettendo i novembre rifaremo la fattoria
da questa parte sue seguirmi la madonna
già c'è un casa c'è un casino all'atroce
e devo mettere a posto
questa è la fattoria fa vitto per linea
cioè ha sempre tenuto st nome ovviamente
anche da mio nonno fa vj grande fa vj's
questo è successo
sto facendo qualcosa non va visto
pisciando addosso certo la vegetazione
da un pò invasa ma so per infatti
l'avevo detto io già prima sotto come la
profusione c'e del terreno buono con un
po di iniziare la ripulirà in un baleno
ma io devo fare questo che non possiamo
chiamare qualcuno che l'ha fatta ed
eccola qui la tua nuovo a casa bella
effettivamente bella spero che non ci
siano accendini a lewis madonna è un
vecchio decreto non aspetta ma lui il
sindaco
eccoti qua ti do il benvenuto sono lewis
sindaco di teli countdown la città dei
pellicani va bene a riprende le robe gol
a vendere posso anche mettere fazzoletti
sporchi mi dai 2 euro
ad onna la sveglia alle 2 del mattino
hai salvato i tuoi progressi che adesso
ecco le sei posso farmi sto tirando
calci e lasciate al letto lasciate non
ho neanche capito e non so come si sa
come si fa come si gioca
c'è un pacco regalo questo non è il modo
per the scatolare i pattini alla zona
non ho ben capito quel tasto destro semi
di pastinaca pastinaca pastina console
italiano
ecco la costruzione fatto iniziare il
sindaco e lee lewis dei semi c'è la tv
previsioni del meteo per capire se posso
dirvi gare campare di terra benvenuti a
cantare di terra si autore di un'altra
ditta per tutti voi no vabbè sto male
c'è un po di merda nella mia terra prova
niente è chiuso a ok si apre alle 9 e
adesso si aperto perfetto era chiuso un
secondo fa era ikea che proprio la casa
compra
compra ho degli ottimi immobili in
vendita settima se ti porta sia al naso
bere qualcosa no si può non sei rapporti
abbastanza buoni colmarlo per entrare in
camera sua ma mar
spiace per va rubriche maru anche un
telescopio vero in tutto questo ragazzi
si è fatta la sera e la cosa impone la
cosa che mi interessa è che immagino che
io non penso che sia con il microsoft e
mi entrano gli zombie perché la parola
di dio
siccome mi alzo alle 6 io andrei a
dormire per adesso per forza perché ai
salotti dei progressi let's go alle 6
del mattino quote del borgo una persona
che vi piace del mattino si va dove alle
10 si va a dormire alle 10 quando mito
molte più debito nove ore sono fresco
voglio anche tanto sealup spreca
giustamente c'è quindi non potevo usare
a caso la posta poste italiane che l'ha
sottratto da un viaggio di pesca da un
viaggio di pesche cazzo vuol dire
l'efficienza e la pesca di normalmente
dovessi scendere in spiaggia prima o poi
c'è una cosa per te va bene
ecco la spiaggia la zia sembro io da
vecchio praticamente cioè la mia vestiti
quasi uguale all aut
willy o la figliolo ho sentito che c'era
una faccia non è in paese piacere di
conoscerti finalmente che bello sto però
posso inviare spieghi che chi cazzo se
sto ancora sto ancora cercava mi chiama
romano ma stando a terni a loro sarà
cercare scaricarlo con me se ne vada
aperto ci ho fatto un gran bottino un
sacco dei pesci boni
chiaramente ci ho avuto i risparmi per
comperarmi una nuova canna da pesca
voglio che la vecchia ce l'abbia tu ci
tengo che l'arte della pesca restituiva
e poi magari di tanto comprare qualcosa
negoziale semplicemente ti stanno
dicendo che c'è la pesca gioco vecchio
posso pescare ha ricevuto canala baldi
bambù poi mi pesca non insegna adesso è
qui che mi mette sonno eccolo che
casanova aiuto non capisco cosa da fare
azioni la barra dietro al pesce il pesce
lì sotto la lavoro anche visto il pesce
stanley ha dentro il pesce non dietro
dentro e non ho capito luca acciuga ho
pescato lanciato non ho capito come si
pero adesso ho capito ci ho piegato due
ore ma ho capito come si pesca è ottimo
meglio tardi che mai ma tra l'altro
ragazzino ma mai pezzi di legno come fai
a portarti di tutti in tasca ma come che
capita sketchup
poi posso prendere un'ostrica sola però
l'età cileni bu come se niente fosse
come se fossero tronchi come se niente
fosse vero sta roba qua te che mi
rappresenta comunque la fine che non ho
capito lo qualunque cosa è stata ora in
rovina mi fa piacere però non la si può
non la posso buttare giù fa un po schifo
cosa che cela dietro questa cosa mi ha
scosso aspetta il mio ritorno all'alba
del tuo terzo anno nonno cosa ma che
[ __ ] altare del nonno all'alba di case
bra gandalf quando parlano signore
aspettare il tuo il mio ritorno a
all'alba del terzo anno guarda ad est
vabbè è detto terzo anno all'alba
madonna io già l'ho già immagine al
momento e motional eni sono al primo
giorno devo passarne altri mille per
praticamente più più di mille per vedere
questa cosa però va beh va beh ragazzi
comunque cibo e di qualcuno finissima e
tradotti in italiano anche
la schermata cosa geniale raga
bellissimo giochi non sei proprio
immaginavo va bene lo stesso ma che
cazzo assagenti problemi marni va beh
raga ho dato solo un'occhiata insomma
prestato due pesci o annaffiato un po di
gente è stato divertente però fatemi
sapere se volete che conti mi perché
scanu è carino per avere vissuto questi
ragazzi degli alpini ragionamento mi
piace fare il sapere se avete continuo
dove faremo più cose insomma magari
spettano anche nei commenti velici
giocate sicuramente sapete più di me è
come sempre signori ci vediamo l'anno
prossimo i due ragazzi
[Musica]